all right Twan
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I grew up on the west side of
Chicago I grew up by Garfield Park
um
tell me about your family uh well my
family I grew up my mama had five kids
all boys I'm the youngest one
so it was like it was kind of like we
always I grew up it was always a big big
old apartment or big house so all my by
me being the youngest one I got to see
everything from like the inside and out
like with every situation like by me
being around everybody as me growing up
the youngest baby in the house like I
always paid attention to everything so
my mama always told me like you're gonna
be you love money you're gonna be a
hustler because like when she used to
hire company I used to be getting them
cups of eyes you know like doing all
type of stuff so by the time when I got
to like 13 years old
I dropped out of ninth grade I went to
ninth grade for like one month
only reason I graduated eighth grade
because I went to the juvenile center
and they just end up gradually putting
me on to the next grade you feel me
because I had gotta end up getting
locked up
but after that I dropped out when I
dropped out of school it was just I went
to I went to Baby doc when I was like 14
got out went back when I was 16 got out
[ __ ] turn 17 and I caught my first time
my first County case a pistol case then
it's just like
it's just like it's just been rough
every it's just been rough I've been on
my own I've been taking care of myself
since I was 15 years old so like I just
seen I just think everything I just sent
it all right
and man it's just like how much prison
time you've done on my whole life I'm 23
now when I was
I did probably when I've been I've been
to juvenile I've been locked up 41 times
but all misdemean is like for not going
to school [ __ ] like that like like the
Police pulling up on me it's 7 30 in the
morning 8 o'clock I supposed to be at
school they gonna take me in I always
got weed on them but then when I turned
17 I went to the Joint I did I took
three at 50 for a gun case I took three
out of 50. I had a gun case and a drug
case I took a year for one case and I
took two for the other then I got out in
2019 went back
to the county ended up having to take
some more time two months later I ended
up taking another three at fifty
came home when I was I came home in 21
because I came home in 19 and I got
locked up again in 19 so I came home at
21. so this is really the longest like I
like I ever been out but like as far as
like the street life like I just sent it
all like I've been taking care of myself
since I was 15 years old and I got a
baby on the way first baby
little girl she'll be here August 25th
you feel me then I lost my brother like
six months ago seven months ago it's
crazy because
God just blessed me with a baby because
of my brother my brother my brother got
killed August 23rd how's your brother
died he got killed in the it was he got
killed in a car it was a it was a
shooter but the car was on the e-way
they was coming from a club
and my homie ends up getting hit but my
homie the one that got hit he was the
driver so by him getting hit right on
the spot the car ended up crashing so my
brother death Trump so it's just like
just like I feel like God just blessed
me you feel me but he ain't blessed me
with the boy but he blessed me with a
little girl so it's like it's really
like a blessing because it's like August
23rd from August 25th like what's the
difference you feel me so I look at us
like a blessing but I still just it's
just like it ain't the same no more like
this is my brother been gone it's just
like
no [ __ ] like don't take [ __ ]
like people like it right like and then
I don't take [ __ ] period I ain't
gonna lie to you like
I get to the point where like I'm gonna
do what I do play games live crack jokes
and do this but like in my eyes I ain't
no [ __ ] like if people that be
around me already know that like yeah
shorty crazy like it ain't even like you
know like that's just me like now
because it's like my brother going I
don't got nobody this is my oldest
brother that's my mama oldest son so by
me being the last it's like I gotta take
care a lot of cause my mama like what
like she lost stuff first and all she
say she don't want to lose her love so
it really just be like I just gotta keep
going you know you gotta keep going I
have my name since I was 13 years old
juice man they've been calling me juices
I was 13. I got my name for my old black
bum from our Hood you feel me just used
to like the way I used to carry myself
when I was a shorty I used to always
talk you know I used to be little I
messed I messed my mouth up when I was
like in elementary schools I always use
my mouth was like I had messed my mouth
up at the gym
I had chilled both of my teeth so I had
ended up getting my mouth fixed but he
always used to play with me you feel me
like I used to oh he thought he was an
old cast I always try to fight on me
feeling like I used to be a little fat
little bully like for the kid ladies to
come in because well I'm from it's a gas
station
so I this gas station I've been coming
in my whole life I was born and raised
through this whole neighborhood Jackson
I'm like all through there so like
anybody gonna tell you juice man they
like they know me like this ain't just
that's just my name like I carry myself
proper I've been taking care of myself
cause like everything like how do you
make money man I mean I sell marijuana
like not like like I'm trying to get a
job now since I just got an ID I mean
like I ain't had I had no idea since
really since I was 19. I'm 23. the gangs
are thick in this neighborhood man like
it's a lot of games like it's getting
worse
because everybody that's coming up this
what they choose it's the lifestyle they
really choose and they choosing to be
like
what everybody else doing it's so many
look like so many young little kids
that's younger than us man in every
neighborhood this man is going to be
rough up and ain't gonna never change it
ain't gonna change cause you got all
these little kids that's claiming the
same gangs as us
whatever whatever games that that's
claiming in their neighborhood whatever
they if they if they they gonna get
involved because ain't Nobody Got no
say-so no mamas no parents these kids do
what they want to do so it's like it
it's like man neighborhood just getting
worse and worse you gotta carry yourself
the way you carry yourself what do you
think the problem is the west side is
probably the just as dangerous as the
South Side no yeah like man we ain't
like you did it for now like
it's the same on both sides now it's
it's just it's worser I'm telling you
it's getting worse because like man yeah
right side is worse than this outside
man a little kill yes
yes is the south side is notorious for
man I'm telling you like I'm look South
Side ain't nobody really out like that
we out every day there's a lot more
activity on the west side yeah as we out
like this this something we've been
doing for years and years and years and
years like since I was going outside my
daddy and you hear me stuff I've been
seeing my whole life so like
what do you think the problem is were
there no opportunities for you as a kid
man we don't learn nothing what role
models did you have we we like your
knives we our own Role Models so
whatever we choose to do we do it for
real for your brothers and gangs like
all my brothers number games everybody
everybody I like my whole family I've
been around
[ __ ] my whole life I ain't gonna lie
to you
like from lights going off to like
everything like I didn't like I didn't
like any probably you probably they
probably you probably but I swear to God
like I truthfully didn't heard all the
Saints at all tell me about
your family growing up you guys are poor
like nah we want now that's what I'm
saying why people never was getting
money yeah you see him but it was just
like as I got older stocks slowing down
so like when I was saying about five six
seven eight nine ten
it was good life was good life was great
you feel man I'm just getting older
stuff started slowing down about 12 I'm
getting to get off doing what I want to
do smoking 13 it was on
drugs are part of your life yeah ecstasy
x x and weed I don't really do nothing
else ever like probably perk saying that
but
I'm a ecstasy Papa like that's all I
like to pop like that's how I end up
when I got my mouth fixed I end up
messing my mouth back up because of the
top arm was rotting out because I love
the pop pills I popped three four pills
a day
I used to I used to be like 190. I'm
only like 130. yeah because I was like
just a lifestyle I lose I live like oh
I can't go two three days without
getting high
like it's like a real like it's real bad
when you with with ecstasy pills you're
addicted yeah it's like I'd be throwing
up and Gotta Get High to stop throwing
up type [ __ ]
so your dad was in your life yeah my dad
is still in my life yeah my mommy and my
daddy is it just
I've been taking care of myself for so
long they let me do what I want to do
it's like they try to tried but it's
like
I want to this this what I wanted to do
like I ain't just stop doing it at 16
years old I'll tell you like 13 type
caught my first case when I was 13 my
first weed case on Laverne Monroe like
like it's like that's just me like uh
I'm a hustler you think there's another
chance a chance that you'll be back in
prison again
yeah I've been dodging it I swear I hope
man I've been dodging I've been doing
good right
and that man up that good like
and I got through so much so many
struggles like within this since I've
been out like just the longest I've ever
been out like I really feel like like
I it's time for a change you feel like
that's what I told my girl like man
since I got my ID now I start filling
out for job applications you feel me
because it's like I got a kid on the way
you feel me and it's like what what I'm
gonna do when she get here you feel me
it's rough like
that's all me and my girl talk about
like we got to keep going I ain't even
got the baby with my girl I got a baby
by a whole nother woman she's just my
girl been messing with me for so long I
met her in 2019. I ain't never met no
girl I go
I swear to God I didn't have five
girlfriends and she still here
like literally like I don't like she
always like we gotta really understand
like it ain't it's a real understanding
what like I can really deal with that
I got thought I could deal with other
situations but it's just like no
she the only thing that's and she gonna
keep it real you feel like I ain't got
time for that
feeling like what do you worry about
what are you afraid of
afraid I die I ain't afraid of dying I'm
afraid of getting hurt because of the
people the type of love I got out here
for the people that I be around
like and it'll be it'll be a sad thing
you feel because like I'm I'm helpful
but yeah I got my own ways when I can
just say [ __ ] like if you even just exit
everybody like but it's like I'm a
helpful person man I promise you I am
like I helped like like so I'll be
afraid to just I'll be afraid to lose my
mama you feel my daddy
if you meet like some of the type of
things I'm afraid I'm afraid of like
just life just really like what's like
what like what's next I'm so many [ __ ]
I know that's gone
you lost a lot of friends yeah my
brother forget like you see him like at
the end of they know my friends but I
lost my brother like there's something I
never picture nothing like like okay all
my mama kids still here still five of us
a few minutes just like when I was in
jail and I just picked that phone I went
over time to use my phone my call it was
something different like it was
something like Whoa
and it was like two days after his
birthday type [ __ ] it was like it really
hit me like and I only been in jail for
like two three weeks when it happened to
my brother like that really made me look
at a lot of [ __ ] different I lost real
homies like my homie that I got right
here toronte like I lost real homies
like I've been had this tattoo since I
was fourth I mean this tattoo these
three tattoos I was like 13. films was
like I lost real homies but I ain't I
never felt that type of pain with my
brother
to the point where I couldn't
flying and that would be the same yeah
everybody telling me I do like my my
attitude
I ain't gonna lie I've been looking at
myself like I do need to slow down I'll
get hurt type but it's like in my eyes
can't nobody hurt me I'm gonna do
something to me whatever emotions do you
go through you get depressed or anxious
or angry uh I'd be I just be angry like
I just be mad because I don't understand
a lot of stuff that happened like I
don't understand like how like it'd be
like it's just like being in the
lifestyle that we live I just be looking
at it like whoa like man I went through
so much like
I just be angry I be real Angry like
um like I like I like just be to the
point where I wake up man type like you
feel like I be looking like what's going
on but it's like
my mind so just caught up in this street
[ __ ] like it's just like and I ain't
even know
like no gang banger type and you see him
like I ain't defeated but I'm just got a
name you feel me like and they speak for
itself
so like
it's a rough lifestyle like a lot being
a hallway sleeping going through this
that ain't got nowhere to go you feel me
it'd be weird stuff going on out here so
like I really just be real angry and
I'll be trying to figure out like wow
like it'd be like I mean first thing I'd
be thinking about hurting something or
don't nobody say nothing to me type they
know I'm coming I'll be around them
every day where you while you just pick
me up from I ain't got nothing to lie
about they know how I'm coming like
ain't nobody gonna get in my way
I promise you like and I do what I do
for myself nobody I'm My Own man you're
part of a gang oh like it's just I'm me
I'm My Own man
I'll be I grew up around Vice Lords
all Vice Lords you've been around after
your whole life my whole life
what's your biggest regret
our biggest regret is just like
picking up gun charge that's my biggest
regret because like now like I'll be
talking to my woman about a lot of stuff
like the felony the gun charge like it
stopped me from getting doing a lot of
stuff like I can get stuff for sponge
but it's just like I mean being who I am
type of street [ __ ] I am I don't be
wanna have time to go do that type of
stuff but you feel like that's the type
of stuff I'd be like man like I wish I
like I regret felonies
and having a class action [ __ ] like that
it's hard to get a job or something like
that yeah it's hard to do a lot of [ __ ]
with felonies in class acts like I went
to jail my second time going to the
Joint was for Fentanyl
so it was like it was one no like ain't
no way I could have got up out of it I
never got a a blessing since I was in
the county they never gave me a low ball
anyone I ever had was 250 D 25
000. I never had no low bond to get out
of jail so every time I went in now I
sat
because I either was fighting another
case on top of another case
so I was just like man I just I've been
in like I've been selling drills for so
long man
like so long like
in all the sauce on the racial [ __ ]
there's a market for it all right I just
saw some of the worst [ __ ] like my when
I was the fourth when I was like 13.
man people in my neighborhood was
getting money like I was I I was a room
to it it was not like it couldn't it
came all in my flush like I got my own
car do whatever I want to do like I I
came up from like 14 to to buying cars
14 when I got out of you before I went
to the Joint before I got 17 I was on I
had a juvenile case and I was on the run
for for two years
I was getting up man I was playing I'm
telling you man I had it man then they
finally ended up catching up with me I
ended up doing a little time coming home
behind like just living like been like I
ain't gonna say like money just been
around but like I ain't been no broke
like it's just like it ain't it just
like it's tight now it ain't the same as
it was when I was 14 and 15. it's it's
quicker and easy like so quick to make
two three thousand
I swear to God a thousand dollars I was
in the going house 800. now you you
gotta work your ass out the one house
with five six hundred you hear me but
that's cool as long as you're doing it
for yourself now you're working for
somebody you ain't gonna never get
nowhere
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned
uh
uh the most the most important lesson
was
to really that like you can't look at
nobody as your friend for real that's
really the most important lesson like
with everything that's going on like you
don't got no homies like cause like
like my lesson is just like not trusting
[ __ ] who I've been around my whole
life type like that's my like and that's
what I've been going through through
these years by [ __ ] that I'm trusting
I ain't never did done two because I'm
so 100
they end up you feel me and I was like
I'm looking at it like
just can't trust nobody feeling like I
just know that like all that back in all
this my homie this is my brother we've
been this the only people I trust he is
my brother that's like you feel
everything like that's crazy because
like
he always told me like
we lost our brother he just always me
and you could be doing this man you
could be doing this and look what we
doing now look what we doing up there
like me and him and the rest of the guys
are on we do whatever we want to do you
feel me we gotta listen to nobody ain't
nobody telling us to go do this and do
that and do that no it's not that no
no no no no no no no
I'm not doing none of that I'm not
trying to hit none of that so I'm really
just like just having my way right now I
do what I want to do
it's fast square with me right now I
just don't trust nobody like that's the
biggest lesson that everybody should be
trying to learn in 2022 because look
everybody just did like like everybody
just gone it ain't never the same no
more
everybody gone
all the real people all the real [ __ ]
is over with and so I it's really
everybody that's out here just like
that's coming up in our generation with
the 20s and if you're even like okay
that's cool but [ __ ] that's still out
here that's 30 like
so wet
um
[ __ ] no more because like them [ __ ]
that's really playing a part
so it's really like I just I just look
at a lot of different I'm moving my home
I got I don't be with nobody unless I'm
at the gas station so like I know what
not to do and what to do like I'm really
Street Smart I mean just telling you
like I know how to move my biggest
lesson is like that I learned you can't
trust nobody you shouldn't trust nobody
so like all right come on thank you so
much for sharing your story
I wish you the best luck with your new
baby all right thanks and everything
else man thank you